there's all kinds of pain chaos and
uncertainty in the Bitcoin market right
now there's three main themes that I
think are worth paying attention to the
first is centralized platforms we have
to remember that Bitcoin is different
than these centralized platforms and
infrastructure I use them just like
everyone else does people take their
Bitcoin and they put them on the
centralized platform but that means you
give up control of your keys one of the
value propositions of Bitcoin is not
your keys not your coins and so if you
give up control of your keys someone
else now has those and they can do what
they want with your assets ultimately
you have to evaluate whether the risk is
worth it but you are violating one of
the value propositions of Bitcoin and
self-custody the second theme is around
leverage as we know Leverage is a hell
of a drug during the good times it can
make good bets even better it's like
steroids on something that's gonna work
but during the bad times leverage can
make a bad decision absolutely
horrendous and that's exactly what we've
seen in many of the blow-ups and
bankruptcies across the industry and
then the Third theme is an important one
to pay attention to it is Bad actors
sometimes no matter how good the
platforms the assets or the rules are
Bad actors will find a way to do bad
things we shouldn't condemn an asset nor
an industry because some people decided
to do a bad thing when I zoom out and I
think about these three themes of
centralization Leverage and Bad actors
that is a cocktail for a disaster and
what we are facing right now is one of
the biggest most crazy most insane
things that anyone could have thought
could happen in this industry and so as
we push forward my guess is that we're
going to try to reverse these three
things we're going to go back towards
decentralization we're going to see
people with much less leverage and we
are going to try to rid the industry of
the Bad actors Keep Your Head on a
swivel stay alert out there Bitcoin is
not going anywhere this industry is
going to continue to grow there are
hundreds of millions of people around
the world all working together to make
sure that that happens and we're gonna
have to do it with more decentralization
less Leverage average and way less bad
people